do you think that you would actually
make a good Viking after having to like
cuz it's been kind of grueling I read
how y'all like shot this and like how
you regular [ __ ] it's like crazy hard no
it really was one of the most trying
experience of my life no I would make a
terrible Viking I mean it's not for
divas that's for sure but it was I mean
it was a great it was a great experience
and you know and I mean I have a story I
mean this is this is like they put a ton
of makeup on you trying to break you
down and there's like there's times
where like just because it's so quick
and demanding that you don't don't have
time to put on makeup and I'll never
forget this one time I I went down was
like screw it I'm gonna do it myself and
I just pulled out this big glob of dirt
and I stuck it all over my face and I
realized after he was
[Applause]
that has been my life for six years that
was a great story
like did you want it
no I didn't have time to take it off so
I just to give you that's your very
method I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this